[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais commencer en vous posant une
question est ce que vous vous souvenez
de l'enfant que vous étiez tout petits
du bébé presque réfléchissez curieux
téméraire peureux moi je m'en souviens
pas mais on m'a souvent raconté que
j'adorais parler et tout petit je
parlais aux fleurs de la tapisserie de
ma chambre pendant des heures mais je
n'avais pas parlé à l'époque donc je
pense que je vais leur donner des sons
plus que des mots j'aimais aussi
beaucoup la musique
j'étais touché par la musique
il paraît que quand j'étais en
maternelle java trois ans la maîtresse
amis de la musique pour vous aider à me
calmer à faire la sieste et moi je me
suis mise à pleurer mais vraiment
submergées alors la maîtresse vient de
voir un email mais qu'est ce qu'il ya
pourquoi tu pleures
alors j'ai répondu que ma que la musique
est venue du ciel qu'elle était triste
en fait ce qui s'était passé c'est que
j'avais été submergés par mes émotions
c'était tellement beau que je m'étais
mise à pleurer je m'étais effondré
j'avais pas gérer cette émotion
voilà moi j'aimais la musique
j'aimais parler j'aimais communiqué sa
j'adorais par contre ce que je détestais
profondément c'est l autorité qu'on
m'impose quelque chose qu'on me dise ce
que je devais faire mes même tout petit
en cp
la maîtresse a voulu nous apprendre à
lire et là mais j'ai refusé j'ai refusé
parce que me l'imposé
et en plus j'en voulais aux autres
élèves qui eux ces moutons lisez
bon alors le vérité c'est qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai quand même appris à choisir mes
combats donc je lis aussi mais j'ai
toujours détesté qu'on m'impose quelque
chose et finalement toute ma scolarité a
été à l'image de mon cp à savoir
compliqué on voulait me façonner
m'imposer me changer c'est un petit peu
comme si j'étais un rond et on essaie de
faire de moi un carré c'était
insupportable pour moi
et plus on insisté plus on m'impose et
quelque chose plus jacques graisser
j'adressais sam agressé en fait alors
j'ai agressé verbalement mais grâce et
physiquement aussi
je me battais pour un oui ou pour un non
c'était compliqué l'école avait deux
heures de colle des notes formidable qui
allait avec
bref une scolarité compliqué on disait
que j'étais nul que j'étais en échec que
j'y arriverai pas et en fait plus on
vous dit plus vous devenez c'était ça
mon rôle d'être nul
et puis finalement à quelques semaines
de mon bac je décide que non je vais je
vais changer
j'en ai marre et je devais envoyer un
dossier pour faire un bts action qu il
se décide que je voulais plutôt faire du
droit et je voulais faire sciences po
voilà c'est ça je voulais faire et quand
je le dis à ma prof principal elle me
regarde et elle rit un peu genre pas
vous
alors à partir de ce moment là je pense
que c'est elle rire de trop c'était pas
possible et à ce moment là j'ai décidé
que j'allais tout changer changer de
rôle
j'allais quitter mon lycée j'allais
quitter poitiers
j'allais quitter la france et j'allais
tout recommencer et six ans plus tard
j'ai intégré une grande banque
d'investissement américaine à londres
j'étais juristes sur un trading floor
une salle de marché alors je me rappelle
de mon premier jour parce que mon boss
ma compagne il va pour ouvert la porte
et juste avant il me regarde
il me dit tu vas voir c'est un peu
bruyant il ouvre à la s'était pas
bruyant c'était assourdissant y avait
200 personnes
un floor immense avec des murs
d'ordinateur un bruit incroyable une vie
moi je devais être juriste ça va être
compliqué et il y avait des gens qui
venaient du monde entier c'était le
c'était le monde les meilleurs du monde
et moi j'étais arrivé j'étais au coeur
du réacteur
j'étais dans dans la city dans le monde
de la finance
le monde de la rigueur le monde de
l'excellence et là on me dit ouais pas
vraiment eu de la chance d'en arriver là
de la chance
non en fait ce qui est terrible avec
cette phrase c'est qu elle anéantit tout
le travail accompli tous les efforts
fournis dans la chance non la chance
elle vient s'asseoir à vos côtés à votre
table une fois le repas est prêt
le couvert est mis et vous l'appelez l'a
peut-être que la chance vient enfin côté
non j'avais beaucoup travaillé pour en
arriver là et encore plus pour y rester
finalement plus travailler elle plus
j'avais la chance alors vous allez me
dire on va super mais où étaient mes
biens en fait ça ce n'était pas du tout
une question je m'étais posé non je
voulais y arriver
c'est ce que j'avais fait puis un jour
on m'invite à participer à une émission
de radio
j'en ai jamais fait pourquoi pas alors
j'y vais il leur hausse a été ou pas
génial tout simplement génial j'ai tout
aimé l'atmosphère le micro le fait de
mettre un casque de s'entendre
finalement de s'écouter parler c'était
fort à la fin de l'émission je rentre
chez moi contente
et puis au fur et à mesure des semaines
et des mois
me manquait quelque chose en fait cette
expérience m'avait quand même chamboulé
mais au bout de trois mois je décide que
je envie d'y retourner
alors je contacte la radio je leur
propose mes services je rappelle je les
relance j'insiste je les harcèle
bon finalement il accepte
voilà il renonce en fait et je commence
à faire de la radio
alors je commence par des interviews et
finalement très vite je veux créer ma
propre émission
balade chromatique c'est une émission
sur la musique est là c'était formidable
chaque semaine j'avais une trentaine de
minutes pour pouvoir raconter des
histoires sur la musique pour parler de
musiciens voyage et transmettre quelque
chose aux gens faire découvrir je
rencontrais des gens incroyables
c'était extraordinaire j'adorais
vraiment et ce qui était plus dingue
c'est que les gens de la radio pensé me
voyez comme quelqu'un d'exalter une
passionnée et quand je leur disais que
je travaillais à la city parce que
c'était quand même mon vrai métier
les gens ne croyaient pas mais non pas
toi ici et en fait ça m'allait j'avais
deux métiers
j'avais deux vies il y avait la rigueur
et le coeur ça m'allait bien comme ça
puis un jour je décide d'inviter un
grand journaliste a participé à mon
émission je sujet me tient à coeur et je
travaille beaucoup
donc tout se passe très bien et à la fin
de l'émission je lui demande s'il peut
pas m'envoyer son livre dédicacé
parce que je m'en étais beaucoup inspiré
quelques jours plus tard je reçois ce
livre alors je me précipite pour lire
cette dédicace et là je m'effondre jeu
mais fonde réellement en pleurs je lis
et en fait ils me félicitent
il me parle de mon savoir magnifique
il me parle de mon immense talent il me
parle de ma voix
c'était c'était la première fois qu'on
me disait ça c'était la première fois
qu'on essayait pas de changer de me
façonner et en fait j'avais l'impression
qu'il me disait tu la trouves est à voir
mais moi je n'arrivais pas à le gérer
moi j'étais submergé j'étais perdu en
fait j'avais j'étais pas habitué à de la
bienveillance comme ça moi j'étais
habitué à défendre
j'étais habitué à battre j'étais habitué
à mettre des objectifs atteindre ma
cible ça oui j'étais une sorte de sniper
de ma propre vie ça je pouvais j'étais
prête mais pas à ça alors d'un côté moi
c'est ce que j'attendais j'avais envie
d'être désarmés ou poser mes armes d'une
certaine façon j'avais envie de faire la
paix la paix avec qui j'étais et là il
me donnait un bon prétexte partir de ce
moment là déjà j'ai pleuré il a fallu
que j'arrête de pleurer
ça a pris du temps je pleure
j'ai décidé que j'avais vraiment envie
de devenir ou de fer qui j'étais
profondément et j'ai réfléchi ça a été
quand même difficile et en fait de tout
ça j'ai appris deux choses la première
c'est qu'il était fondamental pour moi
de se reconnecter à qui j'étais
profondément jean cocteau disait ce
conte reproche cultive le sétois et on
en avait reproché des choses trop
émotive pas assez structuré
alors moi même si au début j'avais fait
un peu acte de résistance
j'avais fini par céder et j'avais essayé
de gommer toutes ces différences qui
sont des forces
ces différences qui sont nos forces ces
différences ces petites aspérités qui
finalement sont un peu comme des prises
pour les autres peuvent s'accrocher à
nous mais moi ça je l'avais nié alors il
était devenu important de reconnecter
avec qui j'étais et finalement je pense
qu'il y à deux questions à se poser
quand on est perdu
la première c'est qu'est ce que j'aime
faire profondément c'est à dire quand je
fais cette chose là je suis profondément
heureux profondément heureuse j'oublie
tout ce qui se passe peut pleuvoir peut
avoir un tsunami j'entends rien je ne
vois pas le temps passer
parce que j'aime éperdument ce que je
fais qu'est ce que j'aime profondément
faire la deuxième question c'est
justement quel enfant j'étais avant
avant qu'on m'impose comme façonne
qu'est ce que j'aimais faire
profondément et souvent cette question
c'est difficile d'y répondre
alors faut demander autour de soi ses
parents sa famille ses frères et ses
soeurs ses collègues ça c'est important
et une fois qu'on commence à savoir un
peu qui on est
la deuxième chose que j'ai apprise c'est
qu'il faut faire absolument savoir ne
suffit pas il faut faire se lancer dans
ce projet qui nous tient à coeur et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que il faut
avoir l'audace de le faire parce que
souvent on va se dire ah non je vais le
faire plus tard demain où on va pas
aller jusqu'au bout souvent ne pas
insister ne pas aller jusqu'au bout ne
pas oser ce n'est que l'expression du
manque de confiance en soi alors j'aime
bien où certains en ont certains n'ont
pas si on en a pas c'est difficile
oui mais ça ne tombera jamais du ciel
jamais la bonne nouvelle c'est ça peut
grandir
souvent on attend d'avoir confiance en
soi pour faire quelque chose mais en
fait ça ne se passe pas du tout comme ça
celle inverse
il faut faire pour avoir confiance en
soi il faut oser faire refaire pour
avoir confiance en soi et plus on fera
plus notre confiance est grande ya
réellement alors j'ai continué à faire
faire des erreurs aussi
mais avec la conviction que chaque
erreur
chaque pas chaque chose que je faisais
allez forcément devenir la fondation de
mon succès un jour
alors il m'a fallu du temps pour avoir
le courage de pouvoir démissionné de
pouvoir quitter mon job à la city partir
de londres
couper le cordon je suis resté 13 ans et
j'ai monté ma boîte de production pour
pouvoir être justement derrière le micro
pour pouvoir parler retrouver
l'atmosphère du studio de la radio
parlée transmettre et faire parler
toujours dans le monde de la finance et
ça c'est ça qui me nourrissais mais vous
savez après tout ce chemin je repense
souvent la petite fille qui est qui
parlait aux fleurs de sa tapisserie qui
pleurait quand elle entendait de la
musique
finalement cette petite fille n'a pas
tellement changé
alors je pleure toujours quand j'entends
de la musique
finalement aujourd'hui les fleurs passé
vous
vous d'ailleurs est ce que vous
connaissez votre différence pourquoi ne
pas aller demander à l'enfant où vous
étiez parce que lui il sait mais c'est à
l'adulte c'est réellement l'adulte ce
que vous êtes devenu qui pourra l'aider
à se révéler merci
[Applaudissements]